today we're talking about Google clouds
architecture framework streaming
analytics and cloud on board I'm mark
merchandani and welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news from the safety of home
Google clouds architecture framework
offers best practices and implementation
guidance for your application design
from operational excellence to security
privacy and compliance reliability and
cost optimization this framework
provides strategies recommendations and
design questions that will help you
build the architecture you need to
succeed Google cloud is bringing
together all of our streaming
technologies into one solution streaming
analytics makes data more organized
useful and accessible from the instant
it's generated built on pub/sub data
flow and bigquery our streaming solution
provides the resources you need to
ingest process and analyze fluctuating
volumes of real-time data for real-time
business insights check out the features
that make this possible and then build
your own streaming pipeline now could be
a great time to learn from home you can
tune in on may 19th and 20th to watch
instructors on Google cloud onboard
break down what it takes to migrate to
Google cloud and explain the basics of
Google kubernetes engine after the
sessions you'll have a chance to test
what you've learned by participating in
hands-on labs and challenges with the
cloud hero online challenge have you
ever wondered how Google cloud technical
solution engineers solve some of your
support cases or maybe you're just a fan
of detective stories either way we've
got a fun and informative deep dive into
how one of our engineers solved the DNS
problem for a customer if you want to
read more about these announcements or
see a full list check out the link have
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you